oh it is good to be the queen at least
financially Lena Headey was pain
reported 1.2 million dollars per episode
for the final season of Game of Thrones
but she only appears in three episodes
for a total of about 25 minutes so if
you break it down further
Lena banked a royal 144 thousand dollars
per minute I made her agent Wow most of
Lena's work was just standing on a
balcony in a soundstage she missed out
on all the fun of shooting all night in
freezing cold with fire bombs everywhere
I'm sure she hates that it was an epic
endeavor to pull off this finale and
we're finally gonna get to see how they
did it this is strange here we are at
the last table read it's like looking
around and seeing your family yeah kid
Harrington getting choked up is how we
all feel knowing there's only one
episode left ever that was a millions
lost shop on David Rose
but now the creators of the show are
giving fans the mother of all parting
gifts a two-hour documentary
appropriately titled the last watch that
drops Sunday May 26 the week after the
series finale and now we get to enjoy
the final hurrah the doc will take fans
behind the scenes of the final season
from how production built the epic
King's Landing set in Northern Ireland
Nikolaj nice for the other day and we'll
never be on anything that is this vast
ever again - the creative ways the crew
kept spoilers from leaking like building
a wall of shipping containers to shut
out the paths every episode has as much
enix as one feature film season 8 also
set a new record I believe I believe
this year the most people that have ever
been burned on screen for a production
22 to be exact
I remember the smell it's horrifying
so we'll go a bit bleak on it this
season's ready bleep well I would say so
very bleep that's the way this show got
a lot of MTV movie and TV Awards loves
today the series scored four nominations
tying Avengers in game and RBG
for the motion is am star Zachary Levi
your boy yeah you gotta host the 2019
MTV movie and TV Awards on June 17
[Music]